not completely but he makes an argument
that I think everybody should take very
very seriously and just to summarize it
in my own words as best that I can what
he what he talks about is how you know
fabulous and amazing and wonderful the
radical openness of the Internet
platform is but also all of the amazing
problems that we have to put up with
because of it problems from spam is one
of the most notorious but viruses people
hijacking computers you know there are
thought to be right now hundreds of
thousands of computers that have been
hijacked secretly to send out spam and
do other nefarious things these giant
botnets of Windows computers that have
been hacked that's troubling and what he
suggests is that it's it's people are
going to get fed up with it and they're
going to actually start demanding
devices that are more locked down and so
things like your iPhone you know it's
it's a pretty lockdown platform and
there's not a whole lot you can do with
it and that raises a lot of concern for
a lot of people I'm a little more
optimistic because I think it's really
hard to replace the open nature of the
internet and the values that it
generates and any kind of closed network
system is going to be so limited that it
can't really compete but I do think it's
something that we need to be pretty
vigilant about to really and in part I
think we need to be not too we should
not be excessively concerned we need to
be concerned but not excessively
concerned about initiatives to change
certain Internet protocols in a way that
might help I mean one of the things
right now is that we've we've struggled
for many many years with the the spam
problem and it doesn't seem to be
getting any better it gets for me
personally it seems to go in ways it
gets better for a while when I upgrade
my filtering software and then it gets
bad again and we can contrast this to
something like facebook i use facebook
for a lot of messages nowadays because i
just never get spam there but i hope we
don't see all email traffic moving on to
a single proprietary platform like
Facebook and so part of the
there is to say look maybe what we need
is an email to point o protocol that
allows for certain kinds of controls
that allows for ways for the community
to exclude people of course I'm not the
first person who said this and I
absolutely have no clever ideas about
how to do it unfortunately but if
somebody had such an initiative I think
I think it'd be wise to look at it and
support it say look actually what we
need is a neutral platform lots of
different people can participate in its
just as open as email and it's not bound
to one vendor and yet it actually works
for a change instead of being a complete
you know disaster like email is so
I think just more of the same you know I
I don't think a lot of people worry
about some kind of sort of apocalyptic
you know virus that sort of brings most
of the internet down for a month or
something I don't think that's too
likely mostly because the kinds of
people who have resources to put into
doing something like that don't have any
interest in bringing down the whole
internet spammers for example spend a
lot of time and effort these sort of
criminal botnets that spend time trying
to steal people's credit card
information and things like that well
they have no interest in is shutting
down the internet you know they need it
to buy stolen goods with the stolen
credit card numbers so those are the
kinds of things that I don't worry about
too much I guess I guess the main thing
is just you know more of the same or
more you know viruses and sort of
nonsense and spam and junk on your
computer but I'm more of an optimist
than jay-z is so